una popular banda de blues regresó
recientemente de una exitosa gira por
tres ciudades donde tocaron para al
menos 120 mil personas ok aquí hay un
dato importante al menos para 120.000
personas si tenían una audiencia de 45
mil en la ciudad de mexico y otras 33
mil en guadalajara cuántas personas
asistieron en acapulco entonces lo que
tenemos que plantear es primero una
desigualdad para poder determinar
cuántas personas al menos asistieron en
acapulco entonces digamos que lo que
hayan asistido en acapulco digamos que
eso es a si les sumamos
lo que asistieron la cantidad de gente
que asistió a la ciudad de mexico más la
cantidad de gente que asistió a
guadalajara
eso debe superar o igualar a 120.000
entonces si le sumamos 45 mil que
asistieron al concierto en la ciudad de
mexico y le sumamos otros 33 mil que
asistieron al concierto en guadalajara
eso debe ser mayor o igual que 120.000
porque al menos fueron 120.000 personas
las que los vieron en concierto entonces
qué es lo que hacemos ahora si queremos
saber cuánta gente asistió al concierto
de acapulco pues hay que despejarla la a
muy bien entonces primero podemos
agrupar esto y cuánto es 45.000 más
33.000
bueno pues estos son más o menos no no
son más o menos son exactamente 78 mil
ok que si le sumamos a eso debe ser
mayor o igual que 120.000 muy bien
entonces cómo le hacemos para despejar
pues restamos de ambos lados 78.000
restando
de este lado 78 mil y restamos también
acá 78 mil del lado izquierdo estos se
cancelan y simplemente me queda que la
cantidad de gente que asistió acapulco
fue mayor o igual que 120.000 menos 78
mil que bueno si si pensamos este que le
quitamos 40 en realidad estamos hablando
de sí perdón si le quitamos 80 mil
entonces estamos diciendo que son 120
mil menos 80 mil son 40.000 pero hay que
sumarle dos verdad porque porque son
menos 78 no menos 80 entonces si nos
quedaban 40 y le sumamos 2 son 42 mil
personas y ya terminamos eso es todo
fueron al menos 42 mil los asistentes